oui oui c'est l'anniversaire de
démission
il allait à tout à l'heure dans le petit
journal pour se moquer de tous ceux qui
ne sont pas des bobos
[Musique]
antoine le vrai c'est parti pour marc
antoine et pour les deux autres des vite
donc je crois qu' une petite surprise un
bref salut mes pieds de beauté talbot
vont petit à petit
aujourd'hui je vous dis à mes petits
chéris aujourd'hui à trente
personnalités qui ont tenu à souhaiter
un bon anniversaire à des huit non non
les gars le gars et vienna 30 boue pour
tenter de boucher le vide ça l'est tout
le monde alors des 8
je te souhaite un joyeux anniversaire
biangue au moins bien qu'au camp lui
candidat le jeu je suis une chaîne qui
fête ses deux ans je suis je suis des
wii la wii wii reste concentré alors
joyeux anniversaire des huit plus que 80
ans de carrière et on est à égalité
ok bon jour on voit mal les polonais
n'ont jamais sa diversité oui cher le d8
je souhaite un joyeux anniversaire à
toute la chaîne ainsi que tous les gros
nico
je vous ai lapsus et personnellement je
sois d'un excellent anniversaire à 10,8
et que les années défilent sur les hauts
talons pour un minimum de les grands se
bouchent changera monsieur hanouna
je vous ai bien et de caméras planquées
gérard rigal bon de trucs tu le
souhaites tu en as des huit le plus bel
anniversaire qu'ils soient et de
souffler encore de très nombreuses
bougies
n'est ce pas mon cher philippe camps
d'euros moi aussi j'aimerais bien me
faire souffler dans la boue liens et oui
c'est l'anniversaire de 18 allée à tout
à l'heure dans le petit journal pour se
moquer de tous ceux qui ne sont pas des
bobos sachez chers des huit que nous
sommes ravis de vous souhaiter vos deux
ans n'est ce pas mon cher jean michel
aphatie tafer antoine ailleurs il est
amusant de constater comme l'âge du
gouvernement est inversement
proportionnel on s'en fout jean michel
joye les anniversaires des huit 8 218
elle est le même âge que mes fans quad à
la bombe et bon anniversaire
faire j'espère que vous jouerez bientôt
en d1a sur la d8 c'est pas terrible
niveau anniversaire bâtard alors des
huit on a deux ans
et bien repasse dans 16 ans tu verra de
quel bois je me chauffe à gouves mode et
8 2 ans comme la première année elle et
écoule la deuxième aussi du coup ça lui
fait une belle paire de couilles zhuhai
aux anniversaires des 8
j'espère que vous aurez une pièce montée
et même à trois pièces montées cuisine
salle de bain pour un bon prix net
vendeur ses portes hier
bon anniversaire d
et à 2 court les méchants dans lequel m
soit nous marque alors moi je dis bon
anniv des 8
on va siffler on va souffler des bougies
le champagne a coulé à flots on va
manger un gâteau miam miam du coup pour
résumer viable c'est tout pour le moment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]